I will try to eat the meat from whatever
I've skimmed what's happening oh my god
[Music]
bicycle
[Music]
bicycle
the future looks very bright and very
festive that's why I'm trying to tell
you to golden tickets to headline baby
you should get out of here well I guess
this is goodbye boom what's up everyone
welcome to simulation I'm your host Don
Saki on very excited to be talking about
hacking Hollywood the stories of science
we have Carrie Cooke girl joining us on
the show hello hello thank you for
coming on Carrie I'm so excited yes yes
you've been a huge inspiration to me and
so many others raw science TV and raw
science Film Festival have been taking
off I've been so grateful to have been a
part of it the last two years and you've
been doing it for almost six years now
five and a half years building this up
Terry's also has 15 years in the medical
device industry most recently in product
development on one of the first
artificial pancreas carries also a
massive promoter of steam education
globally and she's currently building
the first high-tech engineering
university in Afghanistan with digital
citizen fund and a fun fact she was also
a professional ballet dancer for three
years yes yes all of Carrie's links can
be found below highly recommend checking
out raw science TV we'll be talking
about that and a lot of really cool
launch that's coming with that soon
Carrie let's start things off with this
big history perspective we find
ourselves as stewards of Earth what is
your current take on the state of
humanity I I would I think the the
current state is pretty much kind of
existential crisis moment in terms of if
we look back on some of the biggest
times of tumult in history like world
war two it was really preceded by
scientific discovery and that was the
discovery of the structure of DNA and I
believe that you know that that played a
large role in the psychology of people
at that time as well as strange things
that happen in the world and were there
again now you know years down the road
in terms of like what are humans so we
we discovered the blueprint before World
War Two and now we're figuring out like
you know AI and everything else so and
then what do you feel are some of the
Solutions to the existential crises that
we face I think it's just education
basically I mean you know it sounds like
we're almost like teenagers where we
have to learn things about ourselves and
grow and so probably education and
understanding what all these changes and
new discoveries mean and then what would
be a good way to get the education
across the world and what would what
would that structure sort of be like
what are these little nuggets of is it
science is one of these big nuggets that
are so needed across the world for us to
band together on yeah I think science is
pretty it's a universal language that
people can understand you know
theoretically it's a like you know yeah
Universal in the literal sense but yeah
I think that's a thing that unifies
people is a thing that's important and
in terms of our like global education
and storytelling and media plays a huge
role in that not only in just you know
exposing and getting people interested
in being curious but also understanding
the impact of science and tech in a
pretty human way
yeah yeah it's if if we can band
together on science and progressing
society that way I think we have a
massive potential to yeah
to fulfill in our long term now and this
is a lot of obviously what you're super
pushing forward into the world which
really excited to talk about let's let's
get into how Kerry became Kerry how did
this all happen for you mm-hmm
well I guess I I started out as a
professional ballet dancer
when I was a kid I I went into that
probably around close to ten years old
and it was my entire life and I didn't
really think I would be you or do
anything else besides that and wasn't
really interested but I I had a great
interest in science always you know from
from the time I was a kid and but for me
like leaving ballet and learning about
engineering going to get an engineering
degree and and
being an engineer was like very
transformative for me psychologically
and also just in my life in general and
then subsequently also getting the
opportunity about it was like five a
little over five years ago I want to
pitch competition at Caltech - and it
was Caltech and idea lab in Pasadena to
basically win money to start this first
you know kind of like science online
channel and so that progression to
engineering to you know guess being an
entrepreneur was you know it was huge
for me and take us to mind I think so
many people are interested in knowing
what it's like on a on a professional
ballet level this is like really
hardcore body movement and and it teach
us about what goes into this yeah I mean
it's definitely it's a huge amount of
training that goes into it and you have
to be like a hundred million percent
focused on it day and night you know I
spent summers away at like ballet
boarding schools at different countries
and we trained eight hours a day and had
really strict rules was there even
eating properly
yeah well there wasn't any traditional
nutritional guidance at one of the
places but they actually had like food
cards so you know you only ate certain
amount of food at lunch and you had to
be in bed at 9:00 o'clock and they
actually sent someone around to make
sure everyone's in bed you couldn't wear
makeup your hair had to be exactly the
same all interesting yeah and it was
just like eight hours a day training
training training and I loved every
single minute oh yeah yeah but it was it
was intense yeah you're getting ready
for mastery in ballet and then what was
the plug that took you to engineering
yeah well there's a practical part and a
philosophical part and the philosophical
part is just it was extraordinary to me
even since I was like a little kid I
would sit there and think like how am i
moving something you know how long does
it take between when I decide and like
to move my finger and the finger moves
like what's happening there
and you know just extremely interesting
if you've mastered like physical
movement like what what what is behind
all of that and so there I was
interested in science anyway but my
older sister was studying electrical
engineering at Purdue and she inspired
me a lot
oh cool so shout out to my older sister
and and it's also very intense and
rigorous to study Electrical Engineering
cause I guess I mean for that yeah okay
interesting
so so and it's cool how you had in the
kind of existential and philosophical
side of it - plus the Mentos the
guidance and mentorship sort of from an
older sister yeah okay but then how did
it end up being
it was bioengineering yes yes
well one because again like this direct
understanding of the human body and
electricity of the human body you know
like if you sit there as a kid wondering
how do you move your finger then it
becomes interesting later you know to
learn about the heart and the electrical
pulsing of the heart and things like
that but also I have we have a heart a
large history of cancer in my family and
my my grandmother actually died young of
cancer she had both breast cancer and
then later leukemia and my my young aunt
had just been diagnosed and so
biomedical engineering seemed like a
very direct way to do something positive
okay yes and then there was that family
influence of health care issues that
also drove you into biomedical sherry
interesting and then okay so as you get
into that space you know even before the
Caltech and raw science before that what
was what were what were you learning
about healthcare and biomedical
engineering teach us about like some of
these profound realizations were you oh
just in terms of like my education or in
terms of also what you know like in this
past 15 years because like the
artificial pancreas is such an
incredible scientific advancement yeah
so I got to work on pretty amazing
things I mean I just had a job like lots
of people have jobs it was a job but it
was amazing to work on some of the
projects like the one in the last few
years when I started raw science I still
I worked off and on on the medical
device industry to kind of keep things
moving and one of them was on an
artificial pancreas made of stem cells
that basically you could insert this
little pouch of stem cells under the
skin and I think almost any place like
it wasn't you know very specific and it
it would basically start producing human
insulin and regulating itself and I
didn't actually work on the development
of the stem cell line that took like a
ten year process from the all the
scientists before hand but I worked in
product development on you know
determining what was and was not working
about the delivery system and how to
move it forward in clinical trials yeah
this is a massive part of our of our
future is being able to live longer
healthier happy more creative less
pathological disease developing lives
yes yes
now okay so take us to Caltech what was
the competition at Caltech where you
were pitching you're you're like there
is no science TV we need more science TV
it's super wild because I was actually
there's like a there was like an
incubator in ideaa lab that was funded
through idea lab and Hell Tech and
limited partners and I was already
actually working on a medical startup I
was I didn't found it but I was on the
team and so there's like two interesting
parts to that number one is I'd been
working on this medical startup long
story short the founder went to Burning
Man for two weeks and then I was the
only one there and so one day this large
billion-dollar corporation that we
wanted to actually work with and be
partners with the chairman and founder
of that company and maybe like 10 key
executives from the company showed up at
Caltech in the couch and the tech
transfer office and they needed to talk
to someone but no was there but me so I
actually went and had to handle the
meeting and because I have some
experience in medical device like I was
able to handle the main
and and long story short we ended up
having several meetings getting a
partnership and they they thought I
handled that well so they actually
invited me to pitch and see if there was
some yeah so that was kind of neat and
then I pitched but but the really wild
thing is now you know we cover energy
and all different topics and a lot in
space and others and we want to do
things related to distributing media you
know in space and the founder of idea
lab had and I had no idea that this was
the case and I had not even met him
before but but over a decade before he
actually founded created the dot TV
domain and he had the goal of later
creating the first online entertainment
channel that also integrated into space
and the moon and I literally had no idea
and we won so because those elements
were all integrated into it in fact
there weren't really people weren't
really using that TV at the time at all
and because I think there were many
limited partners that that had to be
pitched to but I think that that
probably also swayed their minds yeah
Ronnie is a fried-chicken TV and so yeah
the the dot TV interesting and then the
and then also it's cool how you know you
stepped forward when there was the the
door opened the opportunity opened he
stepped forward took a leadership role
succeeded at what was taking this risk
and and then that catalyzed more open
doors for you this is a very important
process for for young people that these
that on the other side of some of our
greatest adversities our greatest
treasure so we got to really go hard
through those and then also as you're
going through the process of doing the
doing of the pitching and you're getting
raw science set up you're also doing
this from a perspective of science
communication the importance of I want
to I want to hit on this one like I want
to wring the spell a bunch of times
because yeah we have a really good image
here too for this but you know this
this is like Einstein there's like a
public intellectual yes and he went even
with Charlie Chaplin and was going
around and science communication art
right and what has happened why is this
not around anymore to the extent that it
it's a - why are we not celebrating the
scientists and having them speak and
inspire more I don't know why we're not
I grew up in Indiana and I love my my
people in Indiana but it is the home of
the KKK I don't know if people are aware
of this but that is where the KKK
developed and it was it's easy to see
when you grow up in places where
scientific thought might not be leading
that there's a problem so I don't know
why we're not celebrating it right now
but it was obvious to me that we're not
and it's been that way for a long time
it's not new at least you know in my
lifetime it's not new so there is
definitely a desire to change that part
of our culture for a long time and I for
fun would just go around and film things
you know on my own I would spend all of
my that's how I funded before the
channel which I'm sure you're familiar
with doing with like I would just I
would spend all my money in my vacation
time going around the world
I met with Stephen Hawking I met with a
head of Space Research in Russia for
eight years I would just do that because
I intensely curious about things but it
was very important to me to like develop
something that could be a vehicle for
changing that part of our culture and it
had to go through like Hollywood because
there's no you know we had to bust
through Hollywood to do that yeah we
will have to it's just that's the only
way yeah well that's one of the ways
there's there's this - this is very
grassroots like this is very grassroots
like we're not getting into the Academy
Awards you know what and what not with
with this well yeah there's many ways
but as we were talking about earlier the
grassroots parts can be some of the most
important and influential aspect to all
of it and I can give the stats on on
that but we often think well actually
with with a change in media and really
the advent of the Internet
has changed the landscape of media
altogether and so you know up until the
time of the internet it would cost maybe
100 million dollars to create a national
broadcast channel and to do a local one
on a city level would cost around 10
million yeah and now any of us can do
that and it's in critical that we do and
so people often think lately oh we don't
care about true if you don't care about
science or fact that's not that's not
true
media may not be doing the greatest job
but we have people actually do and so a
lot of data is collected that to be
honest studio executives they're not
really aware they're not looking for it
and they're not aware but open slate and
a lot of other organizations they're
they that do media analytics it's shown
that since 2013 if you look at all of
the video channels on the entire
internet the top are like the top 300
thousand channels including TV and
Internet just internet just internet
because we already know that like the
audience is for especially you know for
Millennials and you're is draining very
quickly from TV today like that's that's
a dying carcass yeah you know so just
focusing they don't they're dying and
they're like frogs boiling but so
focusing on Internet video channels
online over the top like 300 thousand
channels the analysis shows that the
most influential and engaged
inconsistent audiences so that means
like they're sharing their liking but
they're also like influencing you know
behavior and their you know all that
their knowledge seekers so the knowledge
seekers that are looking for news or
information are much more engaged and
influential and consistent than sports
entertainment Beauty anything else and
in the knowledge seekers three of the
top ten on the entire Internet are
independent grassroots physics channels
I love that yeah and they rank higher
than TED Talks
they drink higher than CNN blue
Bloomberg Google and Apple in terms of
video yeah shoutout to Vsauce min
physics ASAP science yeah we love these
channels we've had the bookworm for so
long watching and this is one of those
things is when you when you when you
kind of relief when you when you drink
from the fountain of knowledge seeking
mm-hmm
and then you taste the how good it is it
makes sense that you really get heavily
engaged and you're you know like being
sharing you're basically taking the
knowledge that you get from the channel
and then you're going and telling your
friends and getting them to watch it and
we're seeing I haven't actually looked
at like very broadly this trend but at
least for us on our media channels and
like some of the others that we've
looked at for science channels their
engagement is very high in the sharing
so that says a lot about people that
care about science they want when they
learn they want someone else to know
what they learn yeah they're happy that
they learned it and they want someone
else to know so instead of trolling and
being angry on the Internet
they're actually learning and then
sharing it so for us it's almost 50%
like if someone likes and views our
content 50% of the time they share it
that's you and whether that's sharing it
you know thirteen thousand times on one
post or you know just a hundred it still
it seems like it's fairly 50/50 yeah so
I think these are behavior sets and and
things that studio networks have not
really identified or taking advantage of
yet yeah yeah when you're watching it on
the TV there's no you know share button
until you're yeah distribute to your
networks and these are these are
massively important realizations about
about science and this is the optimism
this is where a lot of the you know the
optimism for what we have as potential
okay
so five years now of this so after this
competition you're like I'm gonna go and
make the Film Festival happen I'm gonna
also go and travel and do all these
insane you're insatiable curiosity
getting all the interviews and science
as well yes so tell us about this
process I think it's fascinating to
learn about this from you because you
work very very hard in order to be able
to make the film vessels happen
[Laughter]
yes yes please teach us about what the
operations are like to actually execute
this this is a big deal you're sourcing
well lots of different films from around
the world yeah yeah I mean it's on you
know lots of people start things all the
time and it's grunt work and you know
we're like have our nose to the
grindstone every day but yeah it's
basically the I'd like to give out a
shout out to Mitchell block who helped
he kind of sparked the inspiration for
starting a festival he's a producer and
someone that I hired for the channel
when I started it and he came up with
the idea like why don't you start this
festival and it's really special that he
did that because he was there in the
early days of the starting of Sundance
so yeah that was really nice and no but
yeah but we do have more cool images to
cycle through right now this is a good
time than the other ones around it yeah
so I wanted to give him a shout out for
like helping spark the inspirations to
start the festival and then yeah we you
know just have a slew of volunteers to
be honest it's hard but you know the
hardest part is is really just like
little logistics when you're not a very
large team and doing all that but in in
all things considered you know with
anything these days we can we have so
much ability to do more because of of
apps and like share distributed work
services so it's not so bad
and then what how did you even figure
out you know who were the right you know
films to go out and see and then how did
you figure out what awards to be giving
to the film's this is all very cool yeah
so when we started in terms of the
juried films it was somewhat simple it's
like okay well formats are different
online than they are in theaters so
let's have awards that have a
combination of both you know short less
than 10 minutes over feature-length you
know documentary or narrative animation
you know that that was put into place
but then we created like really fun
innovative awards that are for elements
of films
sci-fi that are not currently recognized
and they should be so one example in all
yeah we'll get well I'll start with
actually maybe I should first explain
about this image and the next in terms
of the Academy okay yeah and then we'll
go back to that topic because of yeah
okay okay so so getting will go well
we'll discuss that alert in a second but
so this is United Artists theater this
past January we just had our festival
there in LA
it was our fifth year and it takes five
years to be an academy qualifying
Festival and then you go through the
formal process of being approved which
means in the future if we get that
approval then we will be qualifiers for
the Academy Awards and if someone wins
an award at our event then it can be
nominated for an Oscar and that was a
really important part of keeping science
and science media elevated year after
year after year and so it was really
special that we had it in this theater
as our qualifying year because the next
image is the United Artists theater back
in the day yeah yeah it was it was that
theater was created by Mary Pickford
Charlie Chaplin and several others that
were key founding members of the Academy
of Motion Pictures of Arts and Sciences
which is behind the Academy Awards and
it's kind of a beautiful thing because
that's Arts and Sciences they are
focused on the technology that enables
us to tell stories and and they created
that theater so it was like super
poignant and sweet for us to be there
that year so then getting back to the
awards I think Kip is the next one Cupid
yeah so this is an example and this was
like a really special moment for us
because actually there are two awards
represented in that picture on the left
is Kip Thorne the famous astrophysicist
and also filmmaker he's behind
interstellar and other things we have an
award in his name the Kip Thorne gravity
award for best depiction of a scientific
principle
and it's for how gravity was depicted
and interstellar and it was a really
novel way to like show people that
phenomenon and so we give that out every
year in his name now two different films
that that to pick that and then it's the
other person in the in the photo is
stephen wolfram founder of Wolfram Alpha
and he has an award in his name as well
that is the Wolfram award for best
technical adviser so we have all these
films and organizations like the science
and entertainment exchange that work to
make sure that Hollywood has science
right but we don't really recognize the
minds that are doing that and in this
case Stephen Wolfram created the
language and the movie arrival so he won
it for that the first year and then
we've given it each other so yeah yeah
to make sure Hollywood has science right
yes so so cool and important yeah yeah
it is really a process of hacking
Hollywood it's so interesting you're
getting you're really getting in from
this is so cool after five years you
become eligible for Academy Awards
qualification which is so huge
that's table elevating and taking it up
to the next stage and I love these like
kippa thorns gravity award for best
depiction of scientific principle these
are very interesting ways to to get
people to think about how do i embed
scientific principles into film yes um
before that one we the we've also
created like workshops so that
scientists and and people in the
entertainment history can collaborate
and they can learn what are the
challenges and how one would go about to
tell their story and a lot of those
workshops are actually like led by
scientists who figured out you know how
to tell their stories and so this the
next year in addition to all of that
were we're adding a science media
marketplace so we're gonna do the
festival in LA and should be formally
announced soon in Costa Rica so we'll
start in LA and fly to Costa Rica and
the idea is to create an international
marketplace just like you'd see in the
Khan Film Festival or Venice or Berlin
where they have marketplaces but
specific to science media whether it's
documentary animation
you know anything where people can buy
and sell their media and services so we
kind of have to go hack it in many
realms yeah and in the second image with
Kip Thorne the one where do you own yeah
yeah so this is um one back one back
yeah yeah this is a really nice story
that's right there
Jacob heaven who is a was a young
student from Western Australia and he
won our first Youth Award for filmmaking
for a film called journey and it's
really beautiful because Kip Thorne
comes to our event every year for his a
related to his award and radio was
actually inspired by Kip Thorne and the
gravitational Center in Australia so he
won the award and we flew him out to LA
and he was able to meet Kip and then of
course you know a year later Kip won the
Nobel Prize for discovering gravity
waves so it's just a nice way that
everything is connected yeah yeah and
then also I want to mention that you
know as we're gonna about to get into
some of the cons some of the other
influence that raw science has had in in
the moment I want to mention some of the
profound films that have actually been
have went through the raw Science Film
Festival and specifically over the last
two years you know the the first year
you had Internet's own boy yes Aaron
Schwartz mm-hmm and teach us about about
that one yeah that our first year that
was one of the winners and that is a
documentary film that in really our
mission is to tell the stories of
science and engage people and that story
is a really important one about open
source data and information and Aaron
Aaron Schwartz was an advocate of those
things and was
he was he he he attacked an academic
publication organization out of I think
it was MIT and he downloaded many many
scientific journals and he ended up
being having many felony counts against
him and was facing 35 years in prison or
million and millions and dollars worth
of fines so he sadly eventually
committed suicide I think at like 26 and
the film chronicles all of that but it's
a really poignant and important story
about open source data yes and now five
years later the Europe is is creating
the open cloud yeah that's very
interesting and the and and it's
interesting because the the internet
came about originally with CERN and the
scientists that were collaborating
around the world at all these different
places to share their information and
data you know for the discoveries
related to CERN and so five years later
it's pretty pretty cool that they're
opening there's science we've had a lot
of conversations all open notebook
science on the show and I'm really
looking forward to what this next
iteration is of collaborative science
pushing the edge of knowledge making it
relatable through the film and through
other multimedia content to the to the
general public to get them engage
inspired yeah the other really powerful
ones on the last two years that I've
attended I've gotten to see unrest on
chronic fatigue syndrome which is very
interesting and then burden of genius
which I don't think any other scientific
film has even maybe necessarily made as
profound of a impact on my life unrest
is actually is really crazy when you
actually get behind of other humans
behind the eyes of humans that
experience chronic fatigue syndrome and
what they actually go through and on
burden of genius very similarly you're
trying to get behind the eyes of people
like dr. Thomas tarsal father of organ
transplantation and the amount of work
that goes into innovation when
your Copernicus basically and you're
saying we can do this this is the truth
we we know we can do some people who you
can't do it it's gonna you're gonna kill
people etc and and you know right
brothers but you know there's just see
these these in have happened throughout
history these people that have taken a
big burden yep yeah and I think that was
really profound I was crying yes I can
actually share information about
original content we're creating that
relates to the director of burden of
genius Chartist so yeah he has a gift at
telling these stories of Heroes of
science that are are making their way
through it all and so since the last
festival we're now working with him to
bring to life the biopic of Jonas Salk
now he had already directed a
documentary feature link that was on the
BBC called the shot heard around the
world about the development of the polio
vaccine and now has written and will be
bringing to life the film is gonna be
called the shot and it is it is it's a
biopic of of Jonas Salk and that same
burden that he carried to bring the
polio vaccine to life and it looks like
it'll be a pretty incredible film kind
of kind of like an imitation game type
feature-length theatrical release is the
intention yeah and this comes this leads
us into a lot of the original content
creation that you're up to with raw
science TV so yeah so to speak to us
about this this is another one of those
ways to engage inspire yeah so we the
platform so we're launching what's
basically like a Netflix for science and
tech films and with better storytelling
with better storytelling so we will
really really tell the stories of
science and so in addition to licensing
and bringing in and distributing that
content we are also creating original
content and that's one example another
one I'm working with a filmmaker named
Osteen who is out of Nigeria he's a
comic who wrote something called
under the Sun and it's a geopolitical
sci-fi thriller about an island it's
based off a real-life island off the
coast of Tanzania where people that have
albinism are living because right now
across the continent people by know
people are hunted like for like their
limbs and their lives because people
believe there is voodoo magic about them
so we're he created this comic called
under the Sun about a superhero island
of elba know people who are involved in
a coup to overthrow the government which
they escape and it's very light-hearted
it's it's like in the theme it's like in
the life you know along the lines of
beasts of no nation kind of film and we
will be bringing that to life as well is
this happening right now in terms of
that issue with Alpine oh yeah it's
happening in fact the there's a woman
who is an independent expert on these
hunting's and human rights with United
Nations who herself has albinism and she
is an official consultant on the project
and it's happening all over currently
today yes that's why there's an island
for real yeah yeah these untold stories
of science and doing it in a really
powerful way to get people to realize
it's very subtle this one well could
contemporary archeology and anthropology
in general is such a fascinating field
because were there's so many things
happening on the planet that were be
basically not able to document on time
yes and it would be very it's very
important to make these places safe for
people to come and document what's
actually happening and make the
scientific content yeah and in terms of
making things accessible to people and
like cross collaborating and the
internet I never I have never met the
comic who created that comic I know him
from Facebook and Silicon Valley Africa
group and he's getting great traction on
the project it is you know it's really
resonating with people and and ended up
collaborating and
and starting to create this so the idea
that anyone anywhere you know we can all
we can all collaborate and build things
yep yep and change that we're really
excited for you're the original content
that comes through the raw science and
and we hope that everyone will will
check it out check out the link below
and get and get signed up for subscribed
to be able to check out what comes onto
the raw science platform these are going
to be some of the best stories that are
told we're really excited for that and I
want this parts also very very important
the first high tech engineering school
in Afghanistan and we have this great
image of the of the girls from the FIRST
Robotics team with Roy maboob here and
you carry as well yes this is this is
such a you know an awareness expanding
moment when you can see young women from
around the world getting engaged in
science and technology yes yeah they
definitely inspired us and it seems
anyone they come across it's an amazing
group of young people we we learned
about them in 2017 and extended an
invitation to join the festival because
what they're doing is is exactly what we
want to promote I was inspired by a 2013
the US State Department report that
showed one of the most transformative
things that can be done in the world is
to educate young girls and women about
science and technology in places where
they currently are not encouraged and so
that that's an important thing to me so
when I learned about them I was very
inspired by what they were doing and
reached out and invited them to the
festival we sponsored them to come it
was it was a huge learning experience
for all of us you know to see especially
when there is a language barrier like we
talked about at the very beginning how
science is a universal language the
girls didn't need to know how to speak
to us and vice versa so everybody got it
and you know all the cultural barriers
just dissolve you know they they kept
their culture we kept off the boat
everybody was able to you know
appreciate an inner
then like do positive things as a result
of that so since then we have partnered
with digital citizens fun that's run by
Roma bub and that's an incredible
organization and and she is incredible
as well and we are working with the
government of Afghanistan to build the
first high-tech university in in
Afghanistan so that's pretty exciting
and that's an engineering focus and also
entrepreneurship - its engineering and
entrepreneurship and the vit one of the
visions is that instead of like where
you you know no offense to the
organizations that focus on coding or
one specific thing the idea is to really
have a very broad yet specific focus on
things like new new technologies that
will be the economies of the future
blockchain robotics AI and focus on
those focuses on very early identified a
you know an inspired talented students
early and then also bring in the arts
and element of steam into it as well
yeah especially for storytelling yeah
yeah so I know there's the Afghan girls
robot team they also have an animation
team you know they have all different
talents and things they're cultivating
and it's very inspiring yeah yeah this
is the type of stuff that gets me to to
get me to get that gets me to realize
that we can have pockets of young people
around the world that are then having
this universal language of science and
yeah yeah and media too I mean you know
I have to admit I was ignorant of Afghan
culture and of Afghan people I didn't
know I don't think I knew any Afghan
people or Afghan Americans and we only
see certain things from the news or from
media and it was it was hugely important
and illuminating to you know meet people
to face to face and like step outside of
those things and we we noticed that a
lot of the feedback that we got after
the team came and it was like very
celebratory everyone was so positive
you know the feedback we got online
regarding that was was really incredible
and you know educated smart people were
like hey we didn't really realize this
before and it has made
realize that the people in Afghanistan
are our brothers and sisters and we
share the same dreams we all want like
similar things and yeah really nice when
one definitely needs a pendulum swing
into the direction of melting pot
culture metropolitan culture where you
see people of all different walks of
life from all different places of the
world and how the peace and dignity and
happiness and prosperity are such
similar passions Ron does a good amount
of work with Afghan TV himself oh really
yeah yeah so yeah so he's also been
pushed he's been passing along some of
the good cultural vibes - yeah we
captured Sadiq Shabaab san leandro he's
a superstar and scanning we had a
concert there that we did our best we
were yeah but there's like you know
there's like you know 500 people their
families you know the young you know
like young boys and girls with their
parents and their grandparents are all
attending you know what I mean so you
see a completely different aspect like
where where do you see you know
Americans going with their parents and
grandparents to like a like an event and
sing and yeah so it was yeah it was a
lot of it was a it was a very profound
awakening in that sense now okay a
couple thoughts on the way out I want to
I want to hear your thoughts about this
on a you know on a large scale
perspective it seems as though you know
with 8 billion humans and exponential
technology you know you gave some of
these focuses of blockchain and robotics
and AI and inspiring that around the
world in these pockets is that would you
say that that then is probably some of
these main focuses for young people as
we go into yeah yeah I mean it's great
timing yesterday was the 500 year
anniversary of Leonardo Leonardo
DaVinci's birth okay and Leonardo da
Vinci was an illegitimate
child who was not allowed to go to
school and hence he was it's like we we
all face adversity as you said and it's
a it's a curse but a blessing so
Leonardo da Vinci because he was not
allowed to go to school and he was not
accepted in the regular professions that
a person might have he was allowed to
explore everything he wanted every
curiosity that he had he was allowed to
indulge and explore and he had the
patronage of Lorenzo de Medici which was
one of the reasons why he could do this
yes exactly
yeah I mean he definitely he definitely
had some help actually unable to go to
school that's why I think he was a
legitimate legitimate and that was
what's that mean for when someone who
said he was born out of wedlock oh we're
not a wet law yeah and then they don't
let you go to school yeah it's weird
and then you know we see many I actually
gave a talk about this in Dublin two
years ago but you know Steve Jobs is the
same thing he was he was illegitimate
but he what he was an orphaned child who
was adopted and we we we see genius
everywhere but there are a lot of people
around the world that are not allowed to
express it or investigate it and so yes
that is a big big goal and long-term
picture is that the principles of
science and the love of it can be
something that anyone who wants to can
can indulge and right now you know in a
lot of places in the world like when
when a student learns about science it's
to save their life it shouldn't be to
save their life it should be be driven
by curiosity and awe yeah yeah yeah the
genius is is is in the creative
potential of all the minds on the planet
and it's just the unlocking algorithm
comes from the basic needs being met and
then the the flourishing of the full
creative potential of the seed and and
and we see that happening like you
set around the world in so many
different circumstances yeah yeah this
is super fun Carrie I want to ask you a
couple questions that we asked on the
show okay
okay our first question is are we alone
in the cosmos I definitely think we are
not alone in the cosmos I mean we life
it seems to be a byproduct of like
chemistry and physical laws that would
be everywhere ourselves definitely think
we're not alone in universe
and what do you think exists outside the
3d reality that we live in here outside
the 3d reality I don't know is that is
that the simulation question I mean I
would think I would tend to think so
because it seems like there are like
limited units of measure on about
everything there are limits and just the
other day I was reading something about
time being discrete instead of
continuous and why Santa Fe Institute
has doing research about why time is to
screen I'm like oh great if time is the
speed that's totally time being discrete
yeah so instead of being like a
continuous flow like our own
consciousness we have a sample rate
unlike this I mean there's like a sample
rate of our existence instead of it just
being continuous well that that kind of
seems like some simulation material but
like time adjusts based on how much
stimuli we take in no just like that
it's like it's like like discrete like
it's not a oh it's not a flow oh it's
like a moment to a hard moment to a hard
move yeah that's something that Santa Fe
Institute is researching right now and
has like but down to like the nanosecond
weights so be yeah I don't have to look
into it more but I was I was reading up
on it and thinking well that's just
great
like is that a little simulation esque
for you well it seems like yeah it's
basically seems like we're getting down
to like maximum resolution but anyway I
would hope it's not I certainly don't
know the answer obviously like but I
hope that it's not but it kind of feels
like it is yeah and carry our last
question for you is what is the most
beautiful thing in the world
what is the most beautiful thing in the
world I would say like unapologetic
self-expression hmm that is emotionally
intelligent yeah unapologetic expression
that is emotionally intelligent that's a
great one why do you say that one
because like it because I think one of
the most important things for humans is
to have agency and to be able to express
themselves but when we express ourselves
we can also like harm people so I think
that people who have a balance between
that are beautiful yeah yeah one one
that knows how to express oneself plus
do it in an emotionally intelligent way
to not harm other people but to have a
growing experience amongst people okay
yeah that's so good yeah I agree I agree
I've slowly been trying to get better
it's a very good skill - very good skill
to learn yeah people that have it are
really wise yeah yeah and they're
vulnerable
you didn't know how to how to say I'm
wrong I'm learning oh yeah humility
humility yeah yeah yeah hair you thank
you so much for coming on our show and
inspiring us and teaching us about raw
science I'm a rock star wheel oh thank
you watch thank you thank you thank you
thank you
and huge thank you for everyone for
tuning in we greatly appreciate it we
would love to hear your thoughts in the
comments below and go and share this
messaging about raw science for all
science Film Festival raw science TV the
links are below go and get more people
talking about Science and Technology and
inspiring more films to be created
around the world unlocking the creative
potential of every person around the
world and you shout out to Ron Vargas
our producer and director thank you very
much
support the artists and entrepreneurs
that you believe in simulations links
are below as well help us grow help us
stay afloat and prosper as well forth
artisan entrepreneur communities - and
go and build the future everyone
manifest your dreams into the world we
love you very much thank you for tuning
in and we will see you soon
[Music]
[Music]